this is a Fox News Alert we are just
getting word out of Riyadh that Saudi
officials are now saying that Jamal
Khashoggi the Saudi journalist who was a
communist also for The Washington Post
did in fact die inside the Saudi
consulate in Istanbul Turkey
the Saudis a prosecutor there announcing
the arrest of 18 people all are Saudis
in this case they are saying that the
death occurred after he quote coral or
fight at the Saudi consulate in Istanbul
these are just from wire reports various
wires
AFP Reuters others were waiting for the
official statement
remember it's 1:00 in the morning in
Riyadh and we are trying to get exactly
what is being said at this hour we're
going to head back live to Istanbul and
we'll bring back John Roberts from the
North Lawn to see if there's any White
House reaction to this this coming
obviously after the Secretary of State
traveled to Riyadh to talk to the Saudis
on this as well as going to Turkey
talking to Turkish officials but again
the Saudis admitting that Jamal
khashoggi was killed inside their
consulate in Istanbul Malt more in just
a mom